[Music]
i started to scream
what what happened all the all the
ceiling was on the floor
i grabbed the ceilings with my hands and
tried to pull them away just to know
where the babies were
hard times are here hundreds of
thousands of people
have already lost their job there is an
institutional
racism in the police we know that and it
needs to be
it needs to be taken out are you okay
where are you going uk
this is the helipad on the top of the
saint george's hospital in beirut
the time is just after six on an
uneventful tuesday evening
and one week on although you know what's
coming next it is still
shocking
down below the hospital's other 230
closed circuit cameras captured the
chaos
the babies were right here nurse pamela
zanoon was in the ward
above the neonatal intensive care unit
they treat premature babies this video
shows her working just moments before
the blast
she feels the first tremor and then the
room collapses
smoke rubble and fear
the other nurses were very badly they
were very badly injured they were old
bleeding they were standing over there
and they looked at me and i looked at
them i was i started to scream
what what what happened they just looked
at me this way and looked at each other
and they were all bleeding
they couldn't even talk all the all the
ceiling was on the floor
i grabbed the ceilings with my hands and
tried to pull them away just to know
where the babies were because the
incubators moved
they weren't on the same place i hold
the three babies and went through this
door
we needed to go to the exit we couldn't
find the exit
we used that the exit was on our left
side now there's nothing
on our left side i walked around five
kilometers on the street so i could
get the babies to another hospital but
you saved them you saved everybody
wow the lebanese prime minister has
stepped down along with the country's
entire government
many people had accused the government
of negligence after an explosion that
killed more than 200 people
and injured thousands more exposed a
fractured nation
suffering through an economic crisis and
years of conflict
i spoke to the son and brother of two
former lebanese prime ministers bahar
hariri
who commends hassan diab for resigning
today i truly believe
change must come and it
i believe we need an independent
government
a non-sectarian that has
in it people that are professional
because there are many issues that needs
to be addressed
as you know we are in a financial and
economic collapse
uh and then what happened on the fourth
uh
the the the massive incident the
horrific incident that happened that
left us still now
with six thousand injured and over 158
people dead
this government must address many issues
primarily the construction the aid
getting an imf package
in and also eradicate
you know it's been 15 years eradicate
that
corruption that is deeply entrenched
in all aspects of government so it has a
lot of work to do but yes i believe that
if we have such government and also a
government that has
few ministers you know we are a small
government we don't need we are a small
country we don't need
30 minutes like we were we need a very
efficient
team that can move for us to take
matters and move forward
but that is completely in divorce
with that marriage between hezbollah and
the world wars
complete divorce
economists expected the uk to go into
recession because of the lockdown but
the actual figures published today
revealed the fastest crash ever recorded
a contraction of more than
20 in three months the chancellor rishi
sunak said the government is dealing
with something unprecedented when we
were chatting a few months ago i said
that hard times were coming
and today's numbers show that hard times
are here
hundreds of thousands of people have
already lost their job
and many more will what i would say
though
is difficult decisions do lie ahead for
all of us
but i want to reassure people that we
will get through this and nobody
will be left without hope and
opportunity why do you think it is that
the uk has been so badly hit i mean
you know the deepest recession of pretty
much any g7 economy yeah i think that's
a it's a very fair question to ask and
as i look at it i think
the primary explanation is the
composition of our economy
social activities for example going out
for a meal going to the cinema shopping
those kinds of things comprise a much
larger share of our economy than they do
for most of our
european comparative countries so in a
situation where you've literally
shut down all those industries for
almost three months for a long period of
time
it is unfortunately going to have an
outsize impact on our economy
when you look at the numbers that we've
just seen you know 24
20.4 percent in terms of the fall in gdp
was that just a price worth paying for
keeping the disease under control i
think we we took the decisions that we
did at the time we did in order to
protect people's lives and suppress the
spread of the
virus and those are the right decisions
but it's also now
right given the progress we've made to
have safely reopened our economy
it's not a sustainable situation to have
vast swathes of our economy essentially
shut down
and that's why we have been able to
successfully reopen bits and do it in a
safe way and as people
get back to going shopping or going out
for a meal or indeed getting back to
their office they will see that it's a
new normal
it's a safe normal we have made changes
guidance is there to ensure that safety
and they shouldn't be too nervous about
the virus should they no i think as
people will see as they go out whether
it's to a shop whether it's to a
restaurant or whether it indeed is back
to their office i think they will see
changes and those changes are quite
tangible and people should take
confidence from those changes to know
that this is now a new safer environment
for me to go and do all those things
the labour mp don butler has accused the
metropolitan police of racial profiling
after the car she was in was stopped in
london
the former shadow equalities minister
filmed the incident in hackney
in which she said officers stopped her
friend who was driving he was just a
little bit of what happened
the other police officer asked me where
i live where i was going that's also
none of your business yeah it's none of
your
do you understand that yeah it is none
when you're driving a car on a public
road
then under the road traffic attack then
we can stop a vehicle and we can
check the driver's license but it's none
of you but it's none of your business
where i'm going
where are we where else are you where
else are you going to drive a car
other than on a public road i will
following the release of that video the
metropolitan police said their officers
had
incorrectly entered the registration
into a police computer
which identified the car as registered
to an address in yorkshire you heard
that reference there
the statement added once the mistake was
realized the officer sought to explain
this to the occupants then were then
allowed on their way no searches were
carried out
on any individual implying that you're
only allowed to stay confined in your
own
area is a real head scratcher because i
don't understand
that or why that is a point of
questioning and then another officer
came
to just inflame the situation and i
didn't understand
why she came to inflame the situation
one officer we're having a perfectly
good conversation and i'm trying to
explain to him
that if you're profiling cars that are
not registered in the area
that seems to be a ridiculous way to
police and also very time consuming
the institution is racist i mean the
other police officers came and said
i can't see what's in the back of your
car you don't need to see what's in the
back of the car
why do you need to see what's in the
back of the car what is
what is that about so there is an
institutional
racism in the police we know that and it
needs to be
it needs to be taken out it is it is
cancerous and it needs to be cut out of
the police force
and it's urgent it's absolutely urgent
um
and i actually wasn't going to go live
with this at all
but because that other police officer
inflamed the situation so much
you know i mean i was getting irritated
and angry at the way she was approaching
me
and i just think it's just such a bad
way to treat people
and this is a police service that's
supposed to police everyone
and i understand that there are issues
and they need to be dealt with but deal
with it in an
equitable way don't deal with it in an
unfair way
and a biased way or a racist way deal
with it properly and then we can all be
on board with that
we're two black people in a car driving
through hackney
and they thought they'll stop them i
mean you can drive anywhere you want to
we do
we don't actually have a police date
that says you're not allowed
to drive from brent to hackney
or from chingford to brent you can drive
anywhere you want it is a free country
so i you know the police have to examine
what's going on and we have to work
together that's the thing
i want to work with the police to get
this
right it is imperative and it is
important and we need to do that
[Music]
[Applause]
it's an almost completely anonymous
building in central caracas but it is a
high security prison
no outsiders have ever been allowed in
here before
this secretive institution has a special
class of inmate
this is where the venezuelans lock up
the foreigners
salvatori cherelli is from southampton
his father is italian
he's serving 13 years for cocaine
smuggling
he admits trafficking several times he
was he says
trying to raise money to come home to
the uk
we went broke so we decided i decided
not that i decided to do that so because
uh
to get more money to go to india because
we don't have money enough to go to
england to survive in england so we have
to sell the houses here
the cars the lands and everything to go
back to europe
in the culture room basically the
library john tweel
looks after the prison books originally
from spalding the 58 year old
is serving 15 years caught with 31 kilos
of cocaine at the airport
like most of the prisoners any despair
has long since gone
when you've been in prison eight years
eight and a half years it's no good
crying i'm going to want to cry
well we're sad to be depressed i'm sick
as it is i can't it's no good work me
getting down and depressed because i'll
get sick more sexy
so it's no good getting depressed about
these things and hopefully my sentence
is finished soon
alexis sanchez is from new jersey in the
united states
a man in his hostel room was carrying
drugs he wasn't he claims
either way he's now serving 17 years for
dealing
mr sanchez wants to be repatriated to
the united states
but with relations between the us and
venezuela at an all-time low
he knows his case is not a priority
maybe because of my nationality
they could uh disapprove this is just an
opinion that i'm having it's not a fact
you understand but we all know that in
politics these type of things
tend to happen from time to time
now it is an a-level results date like
never before
thousands of pupils who never sat an
exam this summer because of the
coronavirus pandemic
collected scores created by a
centralized computer system
while more than a third received one
grade lower than they were predicted
i still had some hope that that they
would see
my last marks and not just my mocks from
year 12 which weren't particularly good
and take that into account unfortunately
they haven't um
so it's not exactly in a good situation
at the moment
what if what if i'd have taken them
would have would i've got a higher grade
but you know what
i'm quite relieved just that it's over
now most people
i don't think they've shown their full
potentials throughout their marks in 30
years i mean you can appeal but i'm
going to wait
until my ucas comes through to see how
that works
and if that's good then i'll go to my
first choice university if not
i'll see how the appeal process works
the government says they can appeal and
potentially fall back on their mock
results instead
we were in a position where we made a
decision to give
young people you know wanted to enhance
the fairness make sure that hence the
options
for appeal make sure that young people
have
the best possible options in front of
them and oftwell are working at
great speed to ensure that this will be
out and
with schools in the next few days
and uh you know i know that the people
at of course work incredibly hard to
ensure that that happens
you've known this was coming for months
people have been warning you of this
situation for months
off call have clearly been bumped into
this at the last minute that's why
they're not doing it
until monday i mean i just don't
understand why
given the fact that you knew these
problems existed with us within the
system
that they were warned about it that you
waited until the scottish
government acted of all things the day
before
a-level results come out it looks
horribly rushed
back of a [ __ ] packet reactionary
policy-making on the hoof
well what you've seen is both england
wales and northern ireland
follow the same approach in terms of
taking this approach because we feel
this enhances fairness for students and
i think that's the right thing to do
anything that i can do to make things
more fair for students
give them the best possible options and
make sure that they get though
grades and the results that they deserve
as a result of the work i think that's
the right thing to do
senator kamala harris has been chosen by
democrat
presidential candidate joe biden to be
his running mate for the upcoming u.s
election
joe biden tweeted earlier today that if
they won they would inherit
multiple crises a nation divided and a
world in disarray
we won't have a minute to waste he said
that's exactly why
i picked her she's ready to lead on day
one
first of all is the answer yes the
answer is absolutely yes
i am ready to do this with you for you i
i just i'm just deeply honored and i'm
very
excited there we are that's the moment
she said yes
capri cafaro a former democratic ohio
senate minority leader is now a
political commentator
and she joins us from hubbard in ohio
good to have you
with us so is this a good pick by joe
biden
i think so i mean joe biden right now is
poised
to at least continue to be in the lead
in
a number of very important states here
uh that are critical to a victory in
november
against donald trump kamala harris is
someone that
i see as a safe pick because she has
been
vetted through being a candidate for
president of the united states during
the democratic primary process
so people are somewhat familiar with her
she has shown herself to have
great debate skills and and legal acumen
both on the debate stage as well as a
member of the senate judiciary committee
she has a
a law enforcement background as a former
prosecutor and attorney general of one
of the largest states in the country
and um you know while she has all of
this experience
and she's somewhat known she's not such
a known quantity
that people are bored with her yeah so
what do how do you think trump
really feels about uh the sort of biden
uh kamala harris partnership he says
you know it would have been his pick but
i mean i i
do you think that's true or do you think
he's concerned
well he says that about pretty much
everybody i mean that's though he's he's
said that about anybody that has ever
been a front-runner oh i hope that's the
case i hope this is the nominee
i couldn't ask for anything better you
fill in the blank of the of the person
you know i think that um donald trump
likes to have a foil he likes to have
somebody that he can run against he
likes to
you know create an enemy and i think
that no matter who was on this ticket
i think that he would be doing that i
think that he um has already shown
that he is trying to paint kamala harris
as someone who is too far to the left
too extreme
out of the mainstream of the american
sort of political ideology
someone who's gonna raise taxes take
your health care away is
not uh is gonna defund the police all
these different issues
and he's also trying to set up joe biden
who has you know a
decades-long track record uh in
government with a voting record that i
think a lot of people see as
more centrist or moderate he's also
trying to paint joe biden as a puppet
of this growing progressive movement in
uh on
the left in the democratic party so
who's to say i think that
you know is donald trump worried i think
it depends on the day depends on the
mood
um and he certainly has a very full
plate
um as the sitting president of the
united states with um
you know this a pandemic that is is
really not particularly controlled a
shaky economy and a lot of uncertainty
we have as well in the united states as
it pertains to
kids going back to school
around 700 people have made the crossing
in the past week
risking their lives on unsafe boats
wisconsin foreski was also out in the
channel today where she witnessed four
boats
being intercepted in just a few hours
it's four a.m on the english channel
we're with matt coker a local skipper
he knows these waters better than most
and in the last two years he's seen the
steady rise in migrant dinghies crossing
the channel
at the moment it looks like there's 13
on board
one female do you think this is one of
the earlier
votes we saw just uh
to be honest it does look red and it
does look
very overcrowded so it could be um
it could be that one we heard about
earlier so and if that's the case it's
managed to cross the shipping lane with
all their
ships coming through you're okay
where are you going
why you're okay
how are you feeling we are very bad
so we're nearly uh right yesterday
what's happening now
uh well at the moment um the border
force is coming in
um to pick them up i think they'll be
here fairly soon so it'll be before they
land
on the shore um and as the border force
arrived then we'll
we'll sort of move away to let them um
let them sort of pick them up and then
deal with them it looks like they're
making progress speed at the moment
so they may well even get to the shore
and if they get to show what happens
if they get to the shore then they
normally push the boat off they get out
and push the boat off and the boat
drifts away
um and then off they go but i mean
there's going to be um
there'll probably be some border force
people waiting down along this shoreline
because they know they're coming in here
they've got their position
will they actually want to encounter
border force i think
quite often they want to be picked up
you know i mean they've just slowed up
now
they've actually just showed up so
they've probably seen the border force
coming in behind us
and they're slowing up um waiting for
them
and i think they want to be picked up
because they want to be processed don't
they whereas if they're
if they don't get processed they've got
no chance of actually getting them
getting granted asylum and for you kind
of more generally obviously today we've
seen
four boats do you ever foresee there
being an end to this
not at the moment really no there's
they're always going to want to come
over if they're going to get a better
life aren't they i suppose anybody would
i mean unless that sort of option isn't
available then they're always going to
try and come over
[Music]
after six months of pandemic enforced
separation
the course of young love can run true
once more
sixteen-year-olds lily and steven both
live with autism
but living without each other has made
lockdown even tougher why do you love
lily so much
could you buy me presents a lot i love
her
yeah and she's funny yeah
i'm beautiful yeah steven brought
flowers a ring
and a promise of marriage when they get
older for the girl that he met on
valentine's day last year
at the special school they both attended
lilly didn't know about today's surprise
reunion
but she doesn't know what she missed
most about stephen
you're gonna name that hug oh so you've
managed to give him a hug today
yeah how good did that feel amazing
what did you think when he gave you the
ring oh my god
you